[Music]
in the screen by edward munch it's a
scream directed at nothing in particular
and it doesn't seem like a scream for
help or someone who has been startled
but something deeper something dreadful
there are figures behind the subject who
seem undisturbed it doesn't seem like a
scenario that seems to warrant a scream
and yet there the person is
screaming
but what makes us so sure in this
painting that the scream is about
something deeper and more dreadful is
the painting's form the way the
environment the face and the body of the
subject seem to warp the painting has a
kind of
dreadful destabilizing wobble of horror
and when we look at it we think the
subject must be feeling that way it's
almost as if the emotions of the
character are too much to be contained
and bleed out into the world around them
this same kind of thing can be seen in
the tragedy of macbeth the latest of
many screen adaptations of macbeth in
the first film directed by joel cohen
without his brother
it's a visually bizarre film to hit
screens in the year of our lord 2021
in the film macbeth's madness doesn't
just come forth in his utterance or
actions it appears vividly on screen
doorways tilt and don't quite line up
the environments shift around him the
landscape of the film is
unapologetically unreal the characters
inhabit a realm that is shaped by their
internal psychological state and it's as
if they inhabit the landscape of their
own mind and we get to peer inside
it's an incredibly unique looking film
but when cinematographer bruno delbanell
started to paint shadows onto the sets
themselves he didn't just come up with
that harebrained idea on his own he was
actually borrowing a technique from a
100 year old movement whose mark on
cinema has been deep and which extends
widely into film and tv to this day this
video is sponsored by curiositystream
get curiosity stream plus nebula for 26
off an entire year today
in 1916 germany banned all foreign films
which led to an explosion of domestic
filmmaking that was uninfluenced by a
lot of outside sources at that time the
country was in social and economic
turmoil the kind that would make it
vulnerable to being captured by a
horrifying authoritarian spirit in just
a few more years and it was in this
environment that german filmmakers
turned to an artistic movement called
expressionism to help them tell their
stories on screen
[Music]
these early expressionist films dealt
with feelings of anxiety oppression
insanity and misery and these themes
weren't just portrayed in the plot they
were built into the lighting and the
sets it isn't just the characters who
have gone insane but almost the
environment itself the city in the
cabinet of dr caligari is like a warped
funhouse version of a city in nosferatu
the exteriors are daunting and shadowy
and interiors are unwelcoming in
metropolis perhaps the most influential
early sci-fi the world is imposing
oppressive and overwhelming
expressionism is a relatively simple
idea express interior experiences
externally in the environment that
surround the subject and in the style of
the work itself and the german films of
this era are incredibly stylistically
provocative and bold they were unlike
any other stylistic movement that had
come before in film and looking at them
now they're still striking to look at
there's a single several second shot
from the touch of evil that i think
about maybe more than any other shot in
any movie here it is
[Music]
there's nothing inherently unnatural
happening in this shot nothing that like
actually defies physics but it's
sinister the world seems to warp it's
like the wall is closing in the
physicality of what's happening in the
shot feels like an expression of the
terror of the character that's being
approached while that one shot in
particular has lodged in my brain for
some reason there are many such shots in
touch of evil the environment is chaotic
slanted in constant conflict and forcing
itself in on the characters
when the nazi regime began rising to
power in germany many of the great
german expressionist filmmakers like
fritz lang fled to hollywood and their
work and style left their mark but there
was one genre in particular that
borrowed heavily from the ideas that had
been developed in expressionist cinema
and that was film noir
i've already shown some examples from
touch of evil but the most iconic noir
double indemnity is a perfect example of
this in these scenes while the
characters plot murder the environment
is dark and prison-like seeming to close
them in and hide them in shadow as if to
convey their psychological state the
third man also does a great job of
illustrating how the expressionist
approach to portraying a setting
influenced film noir this is a different
kind of expressionism though than german
expressionism perhaps one that was more
palatable to american audiences the
environments don't bend to defy physics
but they're structured or lit in such a
way that they're still exaggerated and
warped they're not impossible but
they're definitely not reality either
and the way in which the environments
depart from reality is where the
internality of the characters is being
expressed
there are of course a few modern films
that draw a direct line from the german
expressionist movement the tragedy of
macbeth is the most recent film to
clearly adopt a neo-expressionist style
tim burton is most often cited as a kind
of neo-expressionist filmmaker but i see
flavors of expressionism in terry
gilliam's work guillermo del toro and
david lynch's i think lynch's
expressionism gets overlooked because
lynch's work is often both expressionist
and surrealist and the surrealism steals
the show especially in his later work
but while a film like eraserhead has
surrealist elements its environment and
the landscape that surrounds the
character seem to me to be distinctly
expressionist
but it's the subtler more muted use of
expressionism that begin to appear in
the film noirs that has spread far and
wide into film and tv to this day from
apocalypse now to train spotting there
are many films where scenes or portions
of the film seem to exist in a space
that isn't quite reality where the
architecture sets lighting and general
atmosphere are heightened and this
heightening or shifting of reality is a
reflection of the character's
psychological experiences
while last year the tragedy of macbeth
was explicitly nodding to expressionism
the humans uses it in a more subtle way
to portray the character's anxiety about
decay and aging
it's almost as if the apartment the film
is set in is sick or diseased
[Music]
since season one euphoria has been
making the term neon noir rattle around
in my head but i couldn't quite place a
finger exactly on why the show has none
of the plot elements or stereotypical
characters of war films but what are
these stunning shifts in lighting and
evocatively lit environments that often
appear in euphoria if not an external
manifestation of these characters
internal feelings euphoria feels like a
noir not because of its content but
because it harnesses expressionism like
the classic noirs did
while expressionism has been an
incredibly influential force in film i
feel like the echoes of expressionism
and film and tv don't get recognized as
such in part because it's been a century
since the movement and unless you've
gone to film school or are a hardcore
cinephile you probably haven't seen many
of the original german expressionist
films some of the directors working now
who are using these techniques may not
even be drawing direct influence from
the german expressionists but simply
from the many films since then that were
inspired by them but german
expressionism brought to screen an idea
about how you could approach lighting
and set design and this idea was so
revolutionary that it became such a part
of the fabric of film that now i think
it's almost invisible to us the movement
became just another technique
and her review of taxi driver pauline
kale argues that scorsese's portrayal of
the city is an expressionist one
scorsese may just naturally be an
expressionist scorsese's expressionism
isn't anything like the exaggerated sets
of german directors he uses documentary
locations but he pushes discordant
elements to their limits and the
cinematographer michael chapman gives
the street life a steamy rich pulpiness
it wouldn't be hard to say almost
exactly the same thing about how
euphoria portrays high school often when
a modern film or show uses expressionism
as a technique people just say it's
stylized or surreal
but you can be heavily stylized without
being explicitly expressionist and
surrealism is its own unique way of
bending or warping reality usually it's
a language of dreams or the subconscious
while expressionism is a language of
subjectivity projected outward in film
and tv i think the two can often look
like each other or even be used in the
same work but they have different uses
and effects and it's easy to look at
films like blade runner and blade runner
2049 and simply imagine that the worlds
they portrayed are stylized visions of
the future which in a sense they are but
they are also both direct descendants of
both film noir and metropolis one of the
renowned works of german expressionism
and in metropolis the city isn't just a
portrayal of a possible future its
design is an external manifestation of
anxieties about the present in germany
in the 1920s you can read the cityscapes
in blade runner films as an imagining of
the future but you can also read it as
an expressionist portrayal of our
present environment where all the worst
elements become exaggerated to a
distorted extreme
despite the fact that it flies under the
radar expressionism is there if you look
for it and it may even be gaining in
popularity the coen brothers have made
many films that draw heavily from noir
or are just noirs but why now in 2021
did joel cohen feel compelled to return
to noir's predecessor more directly the
german expressionists projected an
internal anxiety and discomfort outward
but i think it's kind of a two-way
street edward munch in talking about his
inspiration for the scream said he
painted it after he sensed a scream
passing through nature on an evening
walk for much the scream isn't just a
feeling but something he sensed outside
of him expressionism blurs the
boundaries between subjectivity and the
external world and how we feel affects
the way we see the world around us
but the world around us also affects the
way we feel when the environment seems
more off balance crooked littered with
shadows or unreal
perhaps that's when artists start
looking for ways to express
that there's a lot more nuance in depth
to the history of german expressionism
than i had time to go into in this
single video and if you want to learn
more i highly recommend you check out
this episode of crash course film
history on curiositystream all about
german expressionism you can watch the
full episode and the rest of the film
history series when you sign up for
curiosity stream today using my link
you'll get curiosity stream for only
1479 for the first year curiosity stream
has a huge library of documentary and
educational content which by itself is
totally worth it but this deal gets even
better when you sign up for curiosity
stream you'll also get nebula for free
as part of your subscription nebula is a
streaming service where myself and a
bunch of other great creators post all
of our videos early and without any
pesky ads or sponsorships i even have a
few videos that are exclusive to nebula
and i plan to add some more soon
including some coverage of the oscars
this year this bundle is a really great
deal so click the link in the
description for 26 off when you sign up
for curiosity stream plus nebula go to
curiositystream.com
thomasflight or click the link on the
screen today
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video you'll probably enjoy my video
about why david lynch's movies are the
way they are you can watch it here